good afternoon everyone and welcome to
this meeting of uh cabinets uh
item online on the agenda apologies for
absence um do we have any apologies we
do ladies we have apologies from
councillor parry
thank you anne uh disclosers of interest
who will have any disclosures of
interest
i'll take that as no
minutes to confirm and sign the minute
of the meeting held on the 4th of
october
uh are there any issues with the minutes
i see no hands therefore
the minutes are acceptable and will be
signed later
uh no matters to be referred to council
matters for decision by the cabinet
notice of motion unit universal credit
cuts councillor barca
my recommendation is that we get a
simple report on this matter relating to
the
effect on
of universal credit reduction
uh on this council and the people who
live in this district
so this means that we get the report and
we have a debate at the next cabinet
meeting
yes thank you
uh
do i have
sorry you've seconded it
right
does the person who moved the motion get
the chance to address you at this
uh
today since she has made the effort to
come in today
i think she did record that she wanted
to speak
as we were awaiting a report
i'm not sure i see what value
input today would have given we're going
to have a debate on it next time
i understand that uh
councillor junior but i think
it would be better to get the report and
have a full debate on it next time when
we can debate the whole thing
so given i've had a proposal and a
second
uh can i have your agreement to defer
consideration of the of the motion
thank you members of cabinet
uh moving on climate change action
program councillor shenton
thank you leader um the paper before you
today contains a number of constituent
parts that all underpin the three
pillars or ambitions as contained in
section one
these are the action plan the
communications and the engagement
strategy the carbon baseline statement
and the risk register
i'm not going to go into obviously my
new detail
but point out that uh in section 1.6 on
page 13 i think it is
yeah on page 13.
uh it of uh this highlights that 205k is
already committed leaving approximately
295k
i will say just turning to section 4.2.1
um on page 15 that this paragraph only
gives authority to spend any moneys that
are in section 1.6 and only then
when
if we are happy
to go ahead with things like
heat decarbonation plan
especially in view of of uh
possibly having a having another vehicle
another building or merging so
it is a limited um
agreement to suspend that money
uh on another area uh in ambassador
ambition three on table thirty page
thirteen again
uh we've highlighted the need to employ
an officer to focus on the uh adaptation
ambition
and you'll no doubt have seen in the
recent papers from the environment
agency with the snappy headline of adapt
or die
and possibly the the latest u.n
emissions gap report entitled the heat
is on
that we they both spell out the how
serious matters are and that scientists
are now saying that we're currently
heading for a three degree or possibly
more rise in global temperatures by the
end of the century
must learn to adapt to the increasing
climate changes by planning for the
worst and hoping for the best and as you
know this is a really important area of
work that will be shaped to a large
degree by the overdue report that the
met office are producing for us
dave barber has put a lot of work into
producing these papers and
actions etc the joint sdc wsdc informal
meeting of policyholders and lead
members uh the public as well as the sdc
climate panel and their wdc's own
climate panel and wdc's os and stc's osc
have all had a look at these papers had
these ambitions and
i can say that at this point it appears
to be cross party cross authority
includes public views
and it's essential therefore that we do
move ahead with a program officer and a
climate adaptation project officer
everyone's got an opinion on climate
change that's for sure
um
but in a poll at the weekend in the by
the mail on sunday of all papers so
when asked how much people would be
prepared to contribute to the climate
change agenda
the maximum appeared to be 5 pounds per
week or 260 pounds per annum
the truth of the matter is that we'll
need as a country 10 times that amount
um each and every year going forward so
there is a big gap between ambition and
funding of that ambition
and so it is the same for us as a
district council
not everything in this paper can or will
be funded by us
much of it depends on government-led
initiatives legislation and funding
but it is right that we should at least
show in these papers that we've
considered the issues from different
perspectives
and that if we're in a position to
influence or act then we will or should
there's a lot of detail in the papers
and ask members to contact me or dave
barber with any questions outside
this meeting
i will say that this is a living
document
uh in a fast-changing scenario
should cop 26 which started obviously uh
yesterday
if that fails to elicit the national
determining contributions and you'll see
that as and just quoted as ndc's from
each of the 195 plus countries present
at the conference of parties
high level and rhetoric and
grandstanding will not save the planet
from the worst outcomes of failing to
reduce greenhouse gases
this paper therefore
is an attempt to
put some structure into
our own plans um it's not perfect i
wouldn't have professed it to be perfect
but i would ask the recommendations on
page 11
are accepted um but i am happy to take
any questions prior to the vote thank
you councillor shenton i have
uh councillor pemberton
uh
councillor jennings and councillor
harvey and councillor kettle councillor
jennings first then thank you
i know i love data it's always important
do we know roughly when the sort of time
scales are when we're going to get the
met office report
uh it was due first week of october and
i john carefort would be able to give us
that that update um
excellent
so at the moment no unfortunately i
don't know
uh thank you chairman um i should
preface my remarks by saying i am both a
parent and a grandparent so i have as
much interest in
the success of cop 26 and climate
changes as the next person
i'm very concerned about the context of
this
the context is what i'm concerned is
that this authority is discussing
actively the possibility of merging
with another authority with warwick and
the reasons for that are not entirely
but they are largely
financial we can see that we've got a
difficult future ahead on our own over
the next four or five years as have
warwick
part of the reasoning for getting
together is that we intend to save costs
we have to save costs of the order of
four or five million pounds of that
order
my concern is that the
the action plan that's
submitted in this paper is ambitious
it's ambitious and says so in the sense
that
it acknowledges that everything that is
in the plan cannot be financed by the
district council by this district
council
and
i want it clearly understood that my
support for the resolutions for the
recommendations
to make them into resolutions
is based upon
an understanding a clear understanding
that what we have budgeted for as a
council for climate change activities
the 295k i'm all in favor of
but beyond that
i'm not going to put the burden of
shifting the the balance in favor of
climate change
in the circumstances where china is
doing what china is doing india is doing
what india is doing russia is doing what
russia's doing brazil's doing what
brazil's doing and the uk represents
roughly a little over one percent of
total carbon
emissions
what goes on in stratford is important
but it's not crucial it will not make
the difference and i will i will not
vote
for a scenario which says that we are
going to have to significantly increase
the burden to local council taxpayers in
order to fund an ambitious program which
which in reality
is not going to make the crucial
difference between success and failure
i am all in favor having a robust
discussion about what the budget for
next year should be and i'm all in favor
once we've agreed that of seeing that
implemented but i this should this
ambitious program should not be taken as
a blank check or anything like a blank
check to draw upon finances of this
district authority which will not be
there will not be there and therefore it
should be clearly understood that where
where unbudgeted
actions are proposed they are sought and
financed elsewhere from from with
outside this digital authority's
finances
thank you chairman
thank you councillor harvey councillor
kettle
um
just following on and not repeat what
council harvey has said in paragraph 1.4
it will therefore be necessary to draw
on other sources of funding to deliver
significant parts of the ccap
i'll be grateful for portfolio could
confirm that that
currently is not intended to be within
the council's
budget um i know everyone sponsors that
i've got a couple more points
um
as
portfolio holder said his cop 26 has
started today and there may be a whole
raft of issues that come
from well hopefully there will be a
whole raft of issues that come from
cop26
which may have an impact on how this
council operates moving forward
and there may be funds granted to us
that will enable us to um move forward
as well
so i'm i'm taking again your reassurance
that this is a working document that
there may be significant changes that
need to come through it um
following whenever cop 26 finishes on in
in a fortnight's time or or 10 working
days
um and therefore that does have an
impact on page 13
uh as to the maybe
i would consider there might be an
opportunity
to change
our half of the page on page the table
on page 13
and just one minor
amendment to that on ambition one is his
wdc buildings he decarbonization plan
um it should say plan not pan
um but presumably that should refer to
both wdc and sdc buildings
to make it absolute clear that we are
not putting any fundings towards wc but
wdc buildings
until we are in a position where
actually emerged authority and then it
may become appropriate
thank you
uh
councillor shenter do you want to come
back at this point oh would you rather
wait until everyone's had their say
can i come back at this point there's
three three yes go ahead and council
thank you um so on the on 1.4 it quite
clearly uh does say that um
we'll be looking for other forms of of
funding and there is no question to
answer
cancer harvey's
questions uh or comments there's no
question of us increasing the burden we
don't we don't have
any more money other than the 295 000 in
the pot and as far as uh
wdc uh uh concerned and de farber
everyone is aware of my feelings about
adding to the burden or rather not
adding to the burden of the council
taxpayer
in terms of the document itself it is a
living document and it will change as
going forward um in terms of schemes
we've already claimed under the lag
scheme and and also had support for the
electric bike scheme and we will take
advantage of other uh schemes as they
become available hopefully um out of top
26 if not uh during you after or before
and uh and final bit yes you're quite
right it should say plan not
thank you councillor cargill then
councillor junior and council of
pemberton i'll respect your wish to
speak last
thanks
um
there's a theme
and i think it's a fact that we are as
an organization we are short of money or
will be short of money if not already
so picking that up this is an ambitious
but i'll have to say wide ranging
program works
now if it was me doing this um putting
my simple engineering cat on i'd tend to
focus on the major items first and work
my way through freitas rule 80 20
and work your way through it
however if we are going to go flat out
for this
within the time scales then we're going
to need help
and when i say help it's not just simply
throwing money at these things there are
certain elements for example i'll pick
up the two items if i may one is tree
planting and the other hydrogen hub
now both these are looked into fairly
recently tree planting there are
organizations there are things up there
where we can actually um get the trees
and such like and have them planted we
don't own that much land and especially
not land to plant trees in so we need to
help facilitate that with regards to the
hydrogen however i was listening
brothers and webinar
very interesting um bosch as an example
are investing a billion euros in it
we aren't being able to compete at all
with that sort of thing so to make a
difference to to achieve some of the
goals in here which i'm more than happy
to go for we need to be facilitators and
not necessarily put our hands in our
pockets for this because it's just too
big a number so i'm i'm
more than supportive of this i've got
some fantastic initiatives in here but
please you gotta be pragmatic about this
thank you councillor cargill and i
notice your comment about being
pragmatic
counselor junit
i think we um have to be careful with
our language and also careful with our
facts um because although the uk
um
the amount of carbon dioxide it emits
now it is certainly not what it has
emitted historically
our carbon dioxide contributions over
time are considerable and go back to the
industrial revolution and we also
outsource carbon to other countries by
buying in materials and goods
that are made elsewhere and contribute
to other people's
carbon footprint and it is the carbon
footprint that matters and i think if
i'm right we are one of the highest
carbon footprint countries in the world
i think we're about fourth or fifth
um so i think we do have to be very very
careful
but on the pages if i might address a
couple of things i think it needs to be
made clear
that
warwick district council has an ongoing
500 000 pounds commitment to their
climate cha fund that is every year
uh it's it's a commitment that they will
do that every year at the moment the
climate change budget for stratford is a
one-off
and that is up to the district council
whether or not in the budget round
whether or not it wants to um do that
again so
there is a difference between those two
authorities
i welcome the adaptation project officer
but i think we shouldn't forget
mitigation because it shows co-benefits
to people and to our residents
and it helps to keep people uh
counsellors communities on board and and
shows and allows communities to to
contribute um to the the the effort that
we all must take
just a couple of things within this
document i wonder if you could re-look
at and make sure that you do not have
conflict or confusion over certain
priorities we know that we want good
agricultural soil quality soil but we
also know that we want renewables and
solar farms and that in here there are
two priorities that are directly
you know could be directly opposed we
need to have clarity
we need to have clarity over how far
uh building rigs and plannings can
require net zero homes or close to um i
think this is more of a sort of
legalistic thing but we need to be very
careful because i personally believe we
can go farther um than um than than we
perhaps think we can
but we do need to be certain of our
facts on that one and then if we can't
then we need to pressure government to
make sure that we can
um and um the other thing is a lot of
things that are um
uh save uh save carbon actually can also
save money at the same time i know that
the figures for example for an electric
vehicle my i had a secondhand electric
vehicle and it paid for itself after
three years so i think maybe as well we
should think about the savings as well
and maybe a could i suggest that if
there are savings that those are
re-plowed back into into projects uh and
that could then save over the longer
term um i i hope that's um helpful uh
and and it is uh you know i say that
with with the with with the uh meaning
to try and see if i can help the cabinet
um in its decisions
thank you councillor junior
uh
i think one of the issues he raised
there about priorities will become
extremely important given that we can't
do everything
and i'd refer back to the point that
councillor harvey made about budgets
um
i mean we are going to be stretched
and there is no doubt about it uh
climate change will have to compete with
an awful lot of the other priorities
that the council has
in particular delivering the statutory
services that we have to deliver
councillor pemberton
thank you leader
this is about success or failure
and that will be measured
by outcomes
i'd probably argue that this is one of
the areas where pareto's rule might not
necessarily apply where you apply the
biggest and get the 80 20 because
the biggest
are planetary issues
and there's the thick end of 200 heads
of state
either personally or virtually um
attending cop26 who have teams of people
with them
and to be frank
they have to get themselves into gear at
a planetary level
and
that's where the that those big ticket
items will make that 80
frankly
that's where we'll make the difference
and for
all of us
um
involved in climate change and
achieving the
the outcome that we must achieve if we
are to
uh
have a uh have something that we can
hand on to our kids and our grandkids
that we recognize
as civilization
um we all have to play our part
if you're the united states you're china
you're india
you've got some heavy lifting to do
if you are barclays
if you are
jaguar land rover if you are a
multinational if you're microsoft you're
amazon you've got some heavy lifting to
do
as we move further down the chain
in the private sector in the public
sector and
in our individual lives we have to do
what we are able to do
and some of that as i've said in the
past
we will do
having been forced to do it and being
dragged kicking and screaming to do
it but what
where we are at is that
the messages that i think are coming out
of this are not that there is a lack of
ambition
not that there is a lack of
understanding and desire
to change
but that every single pound that we
invest in this has to achieve
a demonstrable outcome that changes out
changes and moves the dial
and anything that
doesn't do that
or that can be done by somebody else
more effectively so somebody else can do
it more effectively they should do it
because they're in the best position to
solve that particular part of the
problem
if we're not being effective with the
spending of every single pound then
that's not that's a pound that's wasted
in the in in what a number of people
have suggested is a war you know put
ourselves on a war footing if we were on
a war footing we would make sure every
single pound was spent wisely on
defeating the enemy well the enemy is
climate change well the enemy could be
us actually but that's another story
so i think
canceled junior is
correct that language matters
but don't under underestimate the desire
to spend money properly and wisely and
that's the message that's coming out
here i mean counselor junior does
mention you know the historical and
those are that's a national issue that
is for us as a nation where you know and
you know the developed world to consider
we need to focus on where we can make a
difference when we can where we can
influence difference to be made
but we have to focus on on achieving
that outcome and i think that's the
message that's coming out of this
that
to achieve success we need to be focused
we need to be targeted we need to
understand that it's outcomes that are
important not what makes
what sounds good what makes us feel
you know that we're making a difference
it's actually what did you do not what
you thought you were going to do what
did you do so i think
what we're saying here is that we will
um
within the funding envelope that we've
got because that's a constraint
um because um it just is we have what we
have to spend and i know um where
warwick currently are
um
that you know that will need to be
reviewed
um in the light of as we come together
if we come together that will need to be
reviewed in light of
cop26
the
that undoubtedly will be the first
checkpoint for this action plan
has there been a demonstrable move by
the nations of the world does that mean
there will be more support does that
make our job easier
um
and you know can you know i i i will
make one particular comment around
things around building rigs and planning
i keep telling you that
climate change will will be writ large
through the local plan and i
get the point that we have to try and
push as hard as we can and just for the
avoidance of doubt
we will push as hard as we can um
and we call take a view as to whether
that's hard enough or not but
do not uh uh under any anybody be left
with the elite the the the thought that
we will not
push absolutely to the line
um
because there is a line because there
are legal processes and we have to
ensure that you know there's no good me
turning around and saying guys you're
going to build zero carbon houses from
2023 if i can't make that happen makes
me look great if i say it's gonna make
us a commitment to it but it's no use if
i can't actually deliver it and that's
what i'm really the i think we all need
to be focused on is what are we actually
gonna deliver
how are we gonna value how we're to
spend each of those patterns and that's
the message that we're supporting an
ambitious climate change program
but we need to ensure that as we move
into the delivery phase every pound is
spent as wisely as we can because we
don't have an option for failure
and so on that basis i'll support the
recommendations i think that we are
making it clear to everybody that there
is a breadth of ambition but that that
ambition is tempered with a reality and
a resolve to make sure that we
actually get the very best out of the
resources we've got so that's where i'm
at with this leader
thank you councillor pemberton
and i noticed councillor kettle wants
one last comment councillor kettle
hey i would absolutely underwrite what
council pemberton's just said and what
the comments from councillor junaid
the one point i would
um
pick up on
uh we do have restraints councillor
harvey has redeferred financial
restraints
the other issue i would like to raise uh
and as you know i do farm
as a profession
is we do still have to feed people
and one of the key issues
one of the key areas of climate
damage is in food miles excess food
miles
and we do have to realize there is that
conflict between
food miles
and um there may be better places
to grow food but if we have to fly out
from new zealand that ain't good
so
we do need to feed people
as well as ensure that we keep the
temperatures down
thank you councillor kettle well we've
had in it
councillor shenton
go on then one very last comment
well it was just to talk
briefly about um this challenge between
agriculture and renewables um
that uh council june had raised and and
i know concerns
um council kepler as well one of the
things that we have raised recently with
the uh with the planners uh and
councillor
parry was uh at this meeting
is the
is the possibility of having a carbon
statement
now
they're they're going to look at this
which would make um
planning
decisions perhaps a little bit easier so
we could see the impacts of various
options
and i don't think anybody
certainly from from
the climate change panel side is under
any illusions that we need to feed the
nation as well as uh have um pvs
around
thank you councillor shenton
well that's been a very wide-ranging
discussion members of cabinet
um
i think one of the things that was
interesting to me is when we talk about
understanding
i have to say from a personal
perspective
i am not sure
that most people have actually grasped
yet
the impact that climate change is going
to have
on everyone on the planet
and i'm also not sure they understand
how quickly it's coming
and i pick up the point that councillor
harvey made
first
off
this is a global problem
and the reality actually is
the countries that are going to matter
in this
are going to be china india the usa and
russia
and that's going to determine whether we
actually get a grip on it or not
uh there is absolutely no doubt about
our commitment to tackling
addition and adaptation
and i have this horrible feeling picking
up the point that councillor shenton
made
that at the end of the day
we're going to do a ha an awful lot of
adaptation
to help our residents
live
good and comfortable lives through the
rest of this century and beyond
so with that
the recommendations on page 11
councillor shenton i believe you propose
these can i have a second to please
counselor pemberton
can i have your agreement and
recommendations one to five on page 11
please members of cabinet
agreed thank you members of cabinet so
moving on to the next item which i
believe
is councillor harvey
thank you leader i'm afraid i've got to
start with an apology for an inaccuracy
in the papers circulated
um
if you look on
table 1 on paragraph 1.2
the number 2 million and eight thousand
nine hundred and seventy seven
should actually be
two million eight hundred and eighty
five thousand nine hundred and thirty
this is due to
an error in not bringing forward slipped
uh 106 monies that should have been
included i apologize for that
that does of course mean that the
figure at the bottom of the table also
changes from 1.698 709
to
2501 662.
subject to that apology and there's
corrections
the purpose of this paper is to keep
members informed of the progress made
over the first six months of the year in
undertaking the council's intended level
of capital expenditure this year
table 2 on page 80 demonstrates the
intention now to undertake expenditure
of up to
21.7 million pounds this year including
section 106 projects
this represents an increase of 7.7
million since the position was last
reported at the end of period 4.
this increase is attributable in very
large measure to the decisions taken to
enter into new waste disposal contract
with biffer and to fund improvements of
the equipment within the district's
leisure centers
if all this budgeted capital expenditure
were to be delivered as reported in
table 1 on page 79 the council's
remaining accumulated capital receipts
and grants to the end of september would
have been reduced from 5.7 million
pounds to 1.7 million pounds
paragraph 1.5 indicates the capital
expenditure of 6.2 million pounds has
already been undertaken by the end of
september in the first six months of the
year therefore the sums spent or
committed amount to 28.8
of this year's available budget of 21.7
million pounds
appendix 2 on pages 87 to 91 provides
summary information concerning the
various projects yet to be funded
through section 106 agreements uh 7.5
million pounds shown on page 89
and those where section 106 funds have
already been committed 1.2 million
pounds as shown on page 91.
appendix 2 also shows that at the foot
of page 91 that just over one million
pounds of community infrastructure levy
funds have now been committed to various
projects around the district in
stratford ulster knapton on the hill and
me and vale i asked therefore leader
that the current position on capital
expenditure and income for the period to
the end of september 2021 be received
thank you councillor harvey i have
councillor junior and councillor donald
i just wonder if i could uh ask a couple
of questions uh i noted in the
government's budget uh that food waste
is to be brought in uh and i'm assuming
will be funded but we don't know but
that's not till 2025
will that have an impact on going
forward on
this council's um budget capital budget
um will we free because i know that
we're going to fund some food waste
bins i believe uh will we get do you
think we'll get that back from the
government and a second one is um can i
just make a you know i have mentioned it
before but i'd just like to say a big
thank you to ulster youth project that
raised 21 000 uh which has contributed
to your budget uh beg and match the 20
000 budget that you um
gave to them and as a challenge that
they should match it and they did
so thank you for that and the third one
i think if i might is on page 91
could i not necessarily hear and now uh
but just afterwards uh
could i have some uh briefing about the
section 106 summary of committed and
uncommitted funds held by the sdc uh
that relate to ulster um the top uh one
two three four um on that page uh all
have um sayings they were raised in
ulster but i believe they're being spent
elsewhere um and
given that we have quite a a need for
affordable housing in ulster i just
wondered whether there's any chance that
um some of that could come back to
ulster eventually
i'm sure we can arrange for you to be
briefed on that chancellor junaid
is she on food waste
yeah well i will um there is a concept
of new burdens funding whenever
government introduced a new um policy
nationally then they are um
supposed to reimburse the local
authorities for the cost of implementing
that that policy i think
we will have to wait and see how we
could benefit from any funding that's
been made available in the budget we
certainly aren't
um stopping the plans that we have in
place at the moment council made its
decision in relation to the the move to
the 3-2-1 um waste collection process
we've now appointed contractors and
therefore what we're implementing in
line with the approved budget and the
approved decision by council
council harvey's
council o'donnell
thank you chair um so it was just some
questions that came back from osc on
capital there's a borrowing requirement
of 15 million 600 000 pounds
what are the annual revenue costs of
this and will this capital produce
revenue savings to compensate for the
additional borrowing costs
counselor harvey
there we go um
because the the funding costs will
depend when
the money is actually borrowed um and
the assets actually purchased so
without knowing the timing of events it
wouldn't be wouldn't be possible to give
you an accurate number what what can be
said is that
in both the instances of of both
contracts one for biffa and one for
mls in relation to leisure centers in
both instances
the contracts as i understand unless
somebody wants to correct me the
contracts both provide that the
rate of interest charged on the funds
borrowed by the council from the public
works loan board in order to fund those
investments there is a margin uh and
therefore um so long as
biffa and mls don't go out of business
and keep to the contract uh the council
will make in fact make a turn on the
money
and do you have any specifics around the
amount that might be made on that or do
we need to wait until we've got more
specifics around the contract is that
what you're saying
i have to say i'm not totally familiar
with the precise terms of the contract i
can i can i can establish that and let
you know thank you very much councillor
harvey
thank you so councillor harvey you
propose the recommendations on page 79.
uh can i have a second to please
councillor shenton can i have your
agreement to the recommendations on page
79 please cabinet
agreed thank you
all right moving on item seven once
again councillor harvey
thank you leader the purpose of this
report is to inform the cabinet of the
revenue picture of the council's
finances at the end of september 2021
i'd like to begin by asking members to
turn to appendix 3 on page 103
this shows that the net budget to be
financed by the council this year is
17.4 million pounds
and if we now turn to appendix 2 on page
101
we can see that the budget for the whole
year is for the total expenditure of
27.2 million pounds and the income from
various sources of 11.8 million pounds
the difference between these two numbers
on the basis that they are rounded
together with the net cost of the cost
of benefits of 182 000 pounds represents
the total amount to be funded from
various sources i.e
15.6 million pounds has set out in
appendix 2.
in addition appendix 2 also sets out
that as a result of the coveted pandemic
the council has received civil
contingencies funding from the
government of 13.6 million pounds of
which 12.9 million pounds has been
distributed in ways consistent with the
government's intentions leaving a
balance of 678
000 pounds at the end of september
turning to the position at the end of
period six we can see that in round
terms the council's expenditure of 16.6
million pounds was 2 million pounds more
than budgeted
this reflects a variety of reasons set
out in paragraph 4.1
the continuing impact of
covet 19 pandemic is similarly
illustrated in the shortfall against
budgeted income to the end of september
of 1.8 million pounds principally due to
shortfalls in revenue of 598 94 000
pounds generated from fees and charges
most notably five hundred seventy three
thousand pounds of revenue lost from the
district's off street parking the
combination of these results means that
the net net cost of services provided in
the first six months of the year
excluding the cost of benefits was 8.1
million pounds
section 4 of the paper identifies the
principal items of variance from their
budgeted figures during the period april
to september notably off-street car
parking having generated 573 000 pounds
less than had been budgeted
whilst the garden waste collection
scheme has generated almost
588 000 more than had been budgeted
once the additional cost of charges to
dry recycling arrangements as a result
of the ethington fire have been met
section 5 provides estimates for the out
turn for the year in full of a shortfall
of 746 000 pounds you'll see that it's
anticipated that the shortfall in
revenue from off street car parking will
be similar at the end of the year as it
was at the end of september
at the same time it's anticipated that
the above budget income received from
the garden waste collection scheme will
be offset by the impact of the
consequences of the eddington fire
section seven of the paper demonstrates
the strain that the pandemic continues
to have on the council's reserve
position which at this stage is
estimated will be reduced by more than
200
000 pounds from 7.2 million pounds to 7
million pounds
appendix 4 identifies the council's
current earmarked reserves which stand
at 13.6 million pounds if the 28.6
million pounds reserve in relation to
business rates is discounted on the
basis that this sum appears as an
earmarked reserve temporarily as a
timing matter before it is allocated
elsewhere within the council's accounts
subject to any further
information that mr snow if he's about
he is
might wish to provide and to any
questions members might ask i ask that
the port report be received
thank you councillor harvey are there
any questions or any discussion
council o'donnell
thank you so from overview scrutiny um a
question on revenue if we look at um
paragraph
5.1.2 um there seems to be a significant
additional expenditure on consultants is
that due to staffing shortages or is it
related to staff bandwidth with relation
to emerging from the pandemic
and the extra work involved with the
proposed merger
um
mr chairman
would
the chief executive like to deal with
that question
i don't i'm quite happy to deal with if
he wants but okay chairman i'm happy to
respond on that um
we have seen an increase in cost in the
planning service for for um
the actual
determination of plan applications and
that has been in the main because we
have been carrying vacancies
unfortunately
the work hasn't gone away if anything
the work has increased in some areas
we've had a an increase in household
applications which don't bring much
income with them but do require as much
consideration as some of the larger
applications so we we have had a deficit
there we have now started recruiting
more
full-time replacements to those roles
and then relying on so much consultancy
mr bill clinton
can i just can i just ask it so does how
does that fit in with the financial
planning around the
buffers that we mentioned when we took
looking at merger and buffers that we
mentioned coming out of the pandemic was
that planned for is that
unexpected
i'd meet so i missed the question this
way so just following on from my
question i understand that it's because
you've had an increase in workload with
small household applications which i
agree are labour intensive aren't they
considering the income they generate
was has that been was that accounted for
with planning coming out of pandemic and
does that then spill into our figures
around the merger because this isn't the
the figures around household
applications are going to continue
aren't they i know councilor pemberton
would like to come in but i can say that
in relation to the planning service and
actually across the board one of the
early decisions that we made was to put
a freeze on vacancies across the whole
board we did not know back in the the
spring summer of 2020 how much
impact the pandemic would have upon the
budgets of the council so we did make a
concerted effort to keep as many posts
vacant as possible however
the work hasn't didn't go away in those
particular areas therefore we did incur
and we have incurred additional agency
costs in those areas
i know that we are recruiting to a
number of planning positions now which
will leave us in a more favorable
favorable position and therefore should
reduce the amount of of cost that the i
i i just pause on that particular side
because you'll you'll also know
on friday um rob weeks left the
organization after many years i'm i'm
pleased to announce we do have a
replacement an interim in
the name of adrian harding who is
joining us on an interim basis so that
that will be charged to the the planning
function as well but but generally
we have more staff we're recruiting to
more staff now and not placing so much
reliance on agency workers
one point of question on that what why
was the decision made to keep positions
vacant than in 2020 was that a budgetary
consideration
so absolutely budgetary because we
didn't know the impact of covid at that
point thank you councillor pemberton
thank you and just to back up the chief
executives uh
we all bought into right at the very
beginning that we were going to have a
recruitment freeze because we didn't
know what was going to happen and i
think all members including members of
oversea were clear because that was
certainly not hidden from anybody that
was a that was a demonstrable decision
made so that can't has come of a
surprise
what did come as a surprise was that
everybody expected planning applications
to fall off a cliff but what actually
happened was it was mages that fell off
a cliff and miners went through the roof
pardon the punt because everybody was
stuck at home and suddenly found time on
their hands to arrange to have all this
stuff done
and i don't think anybody could have
foresaw that
and what we have done is made a
conscious effort now that there is an
understanding that that position is
stabilized around um you know as we come
out of the pandemic that then we recruit
to those posts permanently
we couldn't have known so i think that
is fairly logical i was just going to
make a specific comment on consultancy
costs around planning
um
one i am aware that one of the
significant areas is a planning appeal
in my own ward
where in addition to a barrister we
engaged
quite properly
to specific experts in planning and in
retail uh because of the specific
issues that are that were part of the
appeal and it was not expertise that we
had it in-house
and that will have had a demonstrable
impact on the budget there and i said
and i would say you just have to spend
that money if you're gonna fight an
appeal so um i really just wanted to try
and add some flesh to that um to uh
question you said there's no
no
no concern on the part of osc that there
was a profligate use of consultancies
within the planning team
and i would also say that the
appointment of a planning
lead on an interim basis is absolutely
the right thing given the fact that
we're about to in
engage on a merger situation and you
need somebody to be running and taking
us through that process um and then once
you've got a merged team then you will
then you recruit permanently um so that
would be our wholeheartedly support the
chief executives
stanson approach on that
thank you council of pemberton can i
just come back with a quick comment
there please one of
just let me finish and then come back
and i think you were absolutely right to
flag up the unpredictable outcomes of
kovid
because there is no doubt about it some
of the uh impacts were certainly not
predictable council o'donnell
thank you chair it's just it's just for
clarification reassurance in no way was
i suggesting that osc was concerned
about a profligate use of funds we're
simply asking do you have is it a
bandwidth issue was it temporary and is
it simply out of unforeseen
circumstances no way was it a judgmental
call it was simply asking to see what
help and advice could be offered should
we meet hopefully we don't this
situation again but in no way was it a
negative it was simply asking for
clarification council pembroke and i
thank you for the flesh you put on the
bones around your own ward and the
costly appeal but luckily i'm sure
you've got the right legal advice there
but in no way was it a negative it was
simply providing friendly scrutiny to
see how we could help on that level
thank you councillor o'donnell
councillor junit
yes it's just um it would be useful
again perhaps for ov and scrutiny to
have a look at um overall costs for
example uh there's been the vacancies
freeze and presumably consultancy costs
coming in to cover that but there was
also the deletion of two posts uh which
was the economic development and the
planning enforcement and it would be
useful um to to have a look at that in
the long term but more importantly than
that at the moment is that there are a
number of options that are on there uh
visitor information center shop mobility
and new bus which are uh two of them it
says discussions have started around the
options i would appreciate if overun
scrutiny could have a look at those
options
when you get to that point because we
would like to have an input
and the other one is um
given that um
there was a a
a
position put forward in the last budget
for a bid officer
could you comment on
any outcome on bid outcomes because i
understand that the bid for the gateway
project was not um not successful
it will there be uh progress on that one
irrespective of that bid not being
successful or not
uh i'll certainly pick up the one about
the bid officer uh that money was not
put in the budget the reality actually
is we used the appropriate consultants
to produce the bid
if i'm really honest i don't think any
one officer could have offered the
breadth and depth of experience that we
actually got from the consultants
in terms of the bid
at the moment
we've only heard the outline we've not
heard any backup details when we've
heard further details
then we will communicate them
uh and the uh ovu and scrutiny with the
items that had
discussions started around the options
visitor information center in the shop
ability
i think that's up to overview and
scrutiny i don't set the agenda for
overview and scrutiny
council of pemberton
councillor pemberton and then councillor
barker
so i was just going to ask a question
because um
the question's been raised about um
a piece of work around
um
whether the you know the planning
service um the extent to which it
in this in this last 18 months
has relied upon
agency staff
i suppose the question
if we're going to if we're going to i
all i would all i would uh flag to um
colleagues on overview in scrutiny is
that um
that would seem to be something around
at a you know about how we as an
organization responded to the pandemic i
wouldn't i'm not necessarily sure it's a
it's something you would look at or you
know
would get a rounded picture by looking
at in isolation um if you if if overview
scrutiny feels and you know a look at
how we responded once we've got out of
the thing and lessons learned hopefully
we don't have to learn those lessons
because there isn't another pandemic but
i just i i in in the in the spirit of
trying to be uh helpful um i'm not sure
looking at one individual aspect of how
we
responded to the pandemic without
looking at all the other moving parts
would actually add to how we learn
lessons and move forward it would just
be an observation um so i i do wonder
yeah how you um
whether that would be whether that helps
you at all
i just wanted to support what the leader
had said about the gateway project but
also to
point out that there are i think
potentially more waves of funding coming
when we have greater clarity on the
situation we will think about the ways
forward thank you councillor barker
council o'donnell
it was just for clarification
council
assure you we simply raised this
question whilst looking at the budget
report it wasn't to say we were calling
it in
that's okay just because and i do think
when it comes to a lessons learnt there
are many positives and i don't think we
can in any way underestimate the
commitment of the planning department in
meeting unprecedented demands
so it was just all we were asking was is
it something that you know
could be avoided moving forward that was
all it was in no way critical it was
just it was just you know clarification
on that i don't think there's any need
to respond councillor pemberton
councillor harvey um i wouldn't want you
to close the discussion on this item
before allowing me to respond to two
strings that haven't been picked up in
something that canceled junit said and
she she
lavished as justified praise on the
local group who collected money raised
money in relation to a food project i'm
sure all members of the cabinet would
want to be associated without that
giving of praise well merited
and secondly you asked for an analysis
of section 106 payments in relation to
ulster
i will ensure that you receive it
thank you councillor harvey
i see no more
members of cabinet wishing to
speak therefore the recommendations on
page 93
councillor harvey has proposed them can
i have a second to please councillor
shenton thank you all those in favor
thank you members of cabinet
so without further ado we are on to the
on block items
um
nobody has uh
raised a request for the item to be
discussed so they are items eight
cabinet work program nine climate change
panel 10 stratford-upon-avon
markets forum there are no items of
urgent business so i declare them you've
been close we've missed out item numbers
we've missed out um part c of item
number seven the feeding back issues
arising from overview and scrutiny
there's just two points raised by my
committee they wanted to put forward the
cabinet
just sorry could you say again please
yes so part c issues arising from over
scrutiny we seem to have skipped over
that
oh sorry
it's really brief it's very brief
um so one thing was i think this links
in with the vision for climate change
and then the practicalities in our
district because it's quite nuanced
there's a concern amongst owners of
listed buildings that when they come to
meet standards required by climate
change the conservation department may
be struggling to meet that so it's with
regards to applications from residents
um with air source pumps and double
glazing they may be getting negative
responses from contractors due to
problems raised by the conservation
officers so it's just around this joined
up thinking
that's one thing that was raised and the
second thing that was raised was could
the cabinet please take some time to
look at the environmental land
management scheme the elms
given the rural aspect and nature of our
district some of the committee members
felt it was an important item for
cabinet to look at and i believe there
was also pieces on it in the
broad sheets over the weekend will no
doubt all have had the update from one
of our valued members so those are the
two items from overview and scrutiny
thank you councillor o'donnell and i'm
sorry i missed
issued the rising from wellbeing street
today it was not intentional no i've had
a fair crack today that's fine i would
actually say that the issue of historic
houses and coping with climate change
is actually recognized as a national
issue i read about it in some of the
newspapers so
thank you council o'donnell in that case
having dealt with items 8 9 10 and 11 i
declare the meeting closed
you